Good morning hope you're having a great day. It's Mark Wiens and today is going to be an absolutely incredible
day. I'm on my way to the West Bank in Palestine and i'm gonna visit both Bethlehem and Hebron
which are two very important, very significant cities. And i'm also really looking forward to a local Palestinian
Food Lunch That I'm going to be eating at a local Family's home in Bethlehem
This is going to be a Very special day and i can't wait to share it with you
We drove all the Way through Jerusalem and We Have arrived now into Bethlehem i
Arranged to take This tour to bethlehem and also to Hebron with a Company Called Visit palestine and so
We've Just arrived to the office at palestine our tour Guide whose name Is osama he's gonna meet us here in a few Minutes
But This Is a Nice little cafe
Well a coffee Would be an order before getting started oh?
Double espresso a Fantastic Way to start the morning but such a Nice Pleasant outdoor Terrace area and you have a Nice view overlooking?
Bethlehem here i
can't believe i'm in Bethlehem This is this is amazing
okay
we met Up with osama Aye he's an awesome guy and he will be touring us around Bethlehem and Hebron
Today We Are standing Now on starr street Thus the Very famous street in Bethlehem and
We Will start from Here the tour and i hope You would Enjoy it oh yes i'm already Loving It and he's Already Mentioned That
we're gonna go to a local Family's Home
To eat a a meal and We Got a Lucky day Because the family is having some relatives Over so they're gonna have?
Some amazing Food i can't wait to try lunch Today as Well but first we're gonna Walk Around and we're gonna
Go to the Church of Nativity?
we're in a small assyrian Neighborhood with an old the old Town of Bethlehem
We Just came Up to the rooftop of this guest house and we Have a full 360 view of old Bethlehem this is Beautiful
It's amazing It Makes me want to Just stay in Bethlehem for a Few nights and Explore more
The view is stunning Up
Well That's awesome This Is a tire
We're walking Through The old streets of Bethlehem Now and we're stopping at a at a Bread store and he's getting Ready to
Make some Money ish
yeah
you Just Pulled a Fresh Man iishe
Right Out of That Rock Oven there's a fire burning and There's a Car all Over This
Flatbread Full of time and sesame Seeds Let's Try it oh
so hot
Nice Very Nice Amazing
It'S so hot and fresh and What i love about it is that topping with the fresh Thyme and the sesame seeds
It's like flaming Hot though Right Out of the Oven
That Bakery Was fantastic i have to the flavor of Zatar Lingering in My mouth and Now we are Walking Towards the church of Nativity?
Walking Through These ancient ancient Market Streets This is Beautiful
we made it to the church of Nativity we're entering right Now under this small Archway
and They're Doing restoration for a Number of Years But You can Still see some of the original
Mosaic Which Dates back to the 300s
We are in the karate oh Now this is the stable this is where the
Livestock Where the animals were Kept and this is where Jesus was born over here?
look At It close Up this is good okay car
And Then Over Here on this side This is the the manger Where Jesus Was Placed This is the manger?
It's such a Such a Peaceful Such a Such a Special Place
It was really an Amazing moment to touch The star Where Jesus Was born
That's One of those situations Where you Get the shivers as you're doing It and then it'S he leaves you speechless
so we Just Jumped in the car and we're on our way to the
Where we're heading Now so we're going to the separation Wall and we're gonna see a Very Wonderful hotel in Bethlehem the Waldorf hotel
look at How tall this Wall is
okay we're entering into the walled-off hotel Now Which is a
Boutique hotel Which Faces the Wall
Inside of The hotel You can't take Photos Because it's very Boutique and there's a Lot of Art in Here but There's a Museum behind
There where we've come
Explaining The Situation of The Separation Wall
we're driving There's a Road That Runs Along the wall
But We are driving on our way Now to a host Family That's gonna Host us for lunch
We made it to a local families hold on and we're gonna have a Lunch Here Micah has Already made so many trips oh?
Yes i would love to
Okay we're going Upstairs to the Kitchen for the oven is
Well the Kitchen Is down Here but the oven is upstairs okay oh?
So you have family That's visiting today
so that is Chicken Roasting
Okay it's a Beautiful home yeah?
and Lunch Is in the Oven stuffed it's stuffed Chicken are you the cook yes okay
Awesome
Thank you Very Much
We like This Salads Like This is good chopping some Salad
The Food the Chicken and rice in the Oven is done we're gonna pull it out hey
Judge Mushy Because Mushy
Wow the aroma is amazing oh?
you Can Just Smell That
Smoky aroma
Smells incredible
It's chicken Which is stuffed with Rice and spices and then oh There's meat Also
okay and Then That's put into a plastic bag yes and then it's baked all Together
yes and the plastic Bag sort of Holds in the Flavor and
Keeps All The Keeps all The Juices in i wish you could smell This right Now the aroma of the spices is Just
Incredible and It Is so hot yeah i'm so fresh and look at all That Juice and now each Packet
Goes onto a Plate to serve
That Smells Like Some of The best Roast Chicken You'll ever have
Lunch is Ready We are sitting Down for a Family
It's a Really Unique way of cooking Inside that plastic bag and then he
He took out the plastic bag you can cut open the chicken and Just like a
an irruption of
Seam and You can smell all Those spices in there and it's stuffed with meat and Rice and
Potatoes Aren't on the side It Looks Amazing It Smells incredible The Salad Big Leaves and bell Peppers with the cucumber
The Dressing is Just Lemon Lemon Juice Salt and Pepper and olive oil
Thank you Got some Red it'S a Beautiful bread
and i can't wait to dig into that Chicken all that Chicken Is so tender
It Just Falls apart Tender You can grab some Chicken and grab some of That Rice with it
Put This on my plate
And i'll grab Some where that Rice get a close-up look at That Rice and potatoes it's almost like it's Glistening
Because It almost Looks Like Sticky with all of That Juices from the Chicken
Which i've Just Been soaked into there
okay
Okay i Just cannot I Just cannot Wait to try the chicken a piece of That Chicken with the rice oh?
and some of That Skin Is a Must
Good Amazing
it'S so Good Sack Then Zaki
Zaki oh
it'S so Good
Literally That Rice is like It's like melting Because it's soaked Up all of That Chicken Juices and oils
You can taste a light Spice Blender and oh and there's also meat in the Rice
Giving It Even more Flavor and Then The Chicken is Just Fall apart Tender
Amazingly Fresh
Nice and sour from the Lemon Juice
Okay oh yeah i'm gonna take that potato and i will grab it with That piece of Bread. Oh?
Very Good
Again the potato oh the potato has a Lemon Flavor cut
and Again Just Like The Rice the potato Just Kind of Melts in your mouth Because it's Been cooked for so long and Just has
Absorbed All of Those Chicken Juices and Chicken Oils
I think That's the same Race Rate
This Is a Fantastic home-cooked meal That Chicken
It Just Stays Like completely hot in Throughout youR meal it's still flaming hot
One more dish has come to the table Just an entire bowl of fresh almonds Which have Been Roasted?
Cooked and these are Almonds Right From the tree right outside oh?
and You can Just Put That aside you can Just Put that on your rice or on your food and Just Garnish Just Garnish With
All Those Almonds are amazing They're so fragrant and Crispy i could Snack on those non-stop Forever
Those are like The best almonds You've ever had in your life the best Almond talked about grad my life
and it's Just with nothing on it It Looks Similar to a cucumber but It has Kind of a
Fuzzy Peach Like Skin and you eat It with nothing on it Just the pure Just the pure fucking cous
It'S so good it'S so Juicy and Crisp
It's almost Like a Like a Melon But not Sweet we've also got a plate of Apples Here for dessert and
These are Apples Will right Up the tree they are literally like right Out the doorstep right There
mmm
That's Really sour and
Really Tweet all That The same time This is the apple tree right Here oh?
Yeah and It Just happens to be season of all There's Apples all Over
Thank you Very Much Thank you
Thank you
Thank you and unfortunately we can't Stay. Too long because we're on our way to keep it on but this Was an Amazing meal
I've said this so many Times before but there's nothing as Good as eating a Local
Meal At a Family home and the Food Was awesome but Really the Generosity and the the welcoming nough?
Subfamily Is What Always Shines and That Was that Was fantastic i loved It a meal and Bethlehem
Friendly Generous People This is this is the reason to travel for Food for sure
We're on our way Now to hebron Which is about a 30-minute drive south of Bethlehem
Hey
We drove we made it to hebron and we're stopping first at
Its a Glass Ceramics Factory This and and we've Got His Known Lord ceramics and Glass
Wow Very cool oh That's the giant furnace right ahead
We're watching them Glassblowing Here and it's Just a i'll rage Asleep hot furnace
putting the Glass Within The furnace and then Blowing and Working The Glass
Amazing Heart and it's really Amazing to Watch them he's using three pins but i'm sure he's Just sweating full-Time
you i can Feel the heat Just Radiating on my face right Now
My respect to the Glassblowers They Just Sit With Their
The Heat on their face all day Long and Blow That Glass it's really an Amazing Art to watch?
we made it to the old City of Hebron so ancient oh hello donkey oh he lost his Sandal
And we're gonna Walk Around the old City Now Up here on
This old City Is amazing and we're Walking Through The Market streets Now on our Way to the al ibrahimi mosque
Hello
Lots of Clothing and Food or Walking Through an ancient Tunnel Now
Little convenience Shops Spice Stores oh you can smell the spices you can smell the coffee oh?
That's a Food stall
So Now we're going to the chicken part
okay
Are you looking a minute
We made it into the mosque and we took off our shoes and have come into this this?
Section and we are Here to see the tombs so abraham isaac and rebecca
and Lakiya
and Rebecca solve for four People
Abraham Isaac Lenka and rebecca are all Their Tombs are all here and right Now we're going to the
Two Abraham's Tomb Which is right Through This Door right Behind This gate that is abraham's Tomb
and Abraham Is considered The father father abraham and This is a
It's amazing how peaceful it Is and how ancient it is
Walking on the outside of the mosque and you can see the different Layers of History and
The Construction upon It and the original the original structure was built by King Herod the Great but then the
Crusaders came Along in and Built It almost it's almost Like castle structure like on the outside here?
Thank you
stopping Here for some Fresh Juice i got a mixture of carrot and orange and Lemon i think all Together
All it's really Good you can taste Those Sweet
Carrots In there and That Contrast of That Lemon and orange Just Very Cheap five Shekels for getting all of This Stuff oh
Imagine it's refreshing it'S so good no sugar no sugar added icing at The old City of Hebron
Stop By and Drink the fresh Juice it's Very Nice This is a Place You want to stop
Really Good Thank you
Laughter That Year and Cut Away before Pieces Like This
As Many Sweets
boom, Hello hello hello and it's like Mixed and They they put It with lots of Sugar like wow so
okay try It oh it's it's Kind of like It Feels Like Kind of like a Jelly
Very Sweet
We Got it's like it's like a Jelly
It has a Little Bit of a Maybe for all The Very Sweet Very Very Sweet
did This Dark Alleys
Your Company My Bevel house
We Stopped a Spice Shop and i Just could not resist Buying some spices he has all the hello?
Hello he has all the spices Laid Out Freshly Ground spices he can smell the Aromas
he mixed it all Himself and then shook it in the bag so you have a
Spice Curry Blend all Together
we're at a Pickle Shop Now and he Just has these are Just Beautifully Brightly colored Pickles i love the pink Pickles
There are a Number of different Olives
Tub of Chili sauce
This is Grapes Greeks Pickled
Pickled almonds Thank you okay this is a Pickled Greek
Mmm Really Sour Really Good That's like a a Sour grape like Sour Times 10
but It's endangered
This ancient City of Hebron is Just Absolutely Amazing and so Much History and it's Just ancient
but due to the conflicts that This City has Battled with it
It Really It has a Deserted Feel to it it's Kind of empty it's really Kind of quiet there are a Few Shops
But there's Really Not a lot going on and it has Kind of Almost uh an eerie Feel to it
And
It'S so it's it's so sad Because This is such a
Such a Really Beautiful Place in such a Such an ancient Place with with such immense History
you can Just Get lost in This network That This labyrinth of of
Tiny Alleyways stone Ancient Alleyways and it's Just quiet
we're now driving back Towards Heading back Towards Bethlehem
We Just Pulled Over on the side of the Road there are lots and lots of Grapevines and There's a Fruit stall right Here
Maybe we Can Sample some
Some type of a Local Plum here so marlo
Hmm How's That
Like Sugar oh i know
So fresh and so so sour
Wow That's Good That's Amazing so sour and so Juicy okay
Froot Stop Is complete oh some about some Grapes to bring back to his family and we're on our way back to bethlehem now
This has Been Really One of the the most memorable
most
Incredible Days Of My life Just The combination of being Here in Bethlehem and
Going to the grotto the church of the nativity and seeing the manger Where Jesus was Born Then Having Lunch with that that local?
Lunch With The family and Their Generosity and Then Going on to hebron and
Seeing The The old City as Well as The the tomb of abraham
Really The Combination of Food the history Here
It's an emotional a Special an incredible place to come and
Oh some our guide Was it was really cool he really he really took care of us and
You Really he's a Really awesome guy you gotta come meet osama when you come to Bethlehem and
Also i want to say that we
We took this i took This tour with Visit palestine and i paid five Hundred Dollars
Because We took a private tour we were with the baby i wanted to make a video and
We had included the Transportation as well we came all the Way from tel aviv and
They Really took care of us They're Really a Great Group of People It Was Really a
Fascinating Experience i Learned so much and i still have a Lot more questions Than i have answers
But
It Was it was really a I'm Glad i i'm glad i took This trip and this has Been a
Very
memorable day in my life i
Want to Say a Big thank you to you for watching this video please remember to give It a Thumbs Up if you enjoyed it
I'd love to hear from you in the comment Section Below and if you're not Already Subscribed
Click subscribe Now for lots more Food and travel videos
Goodbye From Bethlehem and i'll See you on the next video thanks again for watching